SPECTER OF LEGALITY MADE TO THE
FISA COURT.
>> THANK YOU.
THE PRESIDENT SAID A LOT OF
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES.
JOHN ROBERTS HAS THAT PART OF
THE STORY ON THE NORTH LAWN.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS SAY THE
DECISION TO RELEASE THE MEMO WAS
MADE BY THE PRESIDENT WITH INPUT
FROM HIS NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
PRESIDENT.
MEETING IN THE OVAL OFFICE WITH
NORTH KOREA DEFECTORS TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP LEFT NO ROOM FOR
INTERPRETATION HOW HE FELT ABOUT
THE MEMO.
>> IT'S A DISGRACE.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES AND MUCH WORSE THAN
THAT.
CARTER PAGE THE TRUMP VOLUNTEER
AT THE CENTER OF THE FISA MEMO
SAID THE OVERSIGHT BY
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS REPRESENTS
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
TWEETED:
IN A CONFERENCE CALL, ADAM
SCHIFF FROM THE HOUSE
POLITICAL STORY THAT IS HELPFUL
TO THE PRESIDENT AND INJURE THE
WORK OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> PAUL RYAN SAID IT WAS
NECESSARY TO GET THE FACTS OUT
MEMO:
INVESTIGATION.
APPLICATIONS AGAINST PAGE.
IN THE OVAL OFFICE PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ASKED IF HE STILL HAS
CONFIDENCE IN ROSENSTEIN?
>> YOU FIGURE THAT ONE OUT.
WHITE HOUSE SAID WOULD IT BE
HAPPY TO HEAR OPPOSING
THE OVAL OFFICE ABOUT ROSENSTEIN
LEFT AMBIGUTTY.